what are the numbers that are being
exchanged between the Steelers and
Le'Veon Bell right now what could they
possibly be because at 4:00 Eastern Time
we're just a few minutes after 2:00
eastern time here sits less than two
hours until the Steelers in Le'Veon Bell
will either come to a long-term
agreement or Le'Veon Bell will be having
to play this season under the franchise
tag and his only option would be to play
under the franchise tag that she can't
strike a long-term agreement after this
four o'clock Eastern deadline right or
he would have to hold out not play at
all which was not an option because he
needs to accrue one more year free
agency one more year to get to a free
agent full-on non franchise taggable
free agency unrestricted free agency
offseason next year that would mean he
would if he wants to miss all the
possible games to then come back and
accrue a year towards free agency he
would be able to skip 10 Pittsburgh
Steeler games 10 Adam Schefter said
today that's an option where that's what
he's thinking about I got my NFL Network
compadre Ian Rapoport on the horn Ian
are you there sir do you tell me what's
going on what is going on I try to just
set the table as best I could on the
levy on telephone what can you tell me
and I know this is something that you
know a lot of players kind of throw
around when they're unhappy with their
contract situation you know I'm
comfortable sitting up the season I'm
not going to show up until you know I
need to get my crew season and we hear
these kinds of things all the time to me
this does not seem like a realistic
option for for Le'Veon Bell because of
the money I mean on its face yes I guess
saving carries would be good for another
team if you know that's the thing he
wants to show his teammates that he's
hoping to save his body for whoever
signs him after the Steelers I can't
imagine that would go over well in the
locker room especially that very vocal
Walker room but I guess theoretically
it's a possibility
but this is a pay-as-you-go franchise
tax you know he gets basically 14 and a
half million dollars divided over 17
weeks so if he skips half the season he
gets half the money so his Le'Veon Bell
really going to give up seven or eight
million dollars to save his legs for a
payday he thinks is coming but doesn't
know is actually coming to me it does
not seem like a realistic option so what
is the holdup I mean because it seems to
me what what is happening is that the
Steelers don't want to set a precedent
in paying him like a wide receiver even
though his numbers are better than many
wide receivers in terms of catches it
may not be yards per catch and even if
it is yards per catch it's uh you know
it's a it's catching one in the flat
it's the screen it's etc it's not like
going deep when he has yards after catch
but he is a remarkable player and a
difference maker of the first variety in
the NFL is that essentially the the
argument that's going on between these
two sides right now yeah I mean that is
what Le'Veon Bell believes that he
should be paid like a the best running
back in the NFL and one of the best slot
receivers I've watched him play I know a
little bit about football yes it's a
pretty good argument he is a great great
player and probably would be one of the
best in the NFL at either position the
problem is it doesn't really work like
that you know like you just don't get
double the salary because you're double
the player I mean it's you know she's
not going to get 17 million dollars a
year you know last year remember he
turned down a deal that was I believe
five years 60 million that averaged 15
million over the first two years this
year if a deal is going to get done it
would have to average at the least
fourteen and a half million dollars over
the entirety of the deal I'm not sure
they're there yet honestly the Steelers
so you know I think we'll pass the point
of bail hoping for receiver money I
think now will you'd like is at the very
least just the average of the franchise
tag and I'm not sure that's where they
are
and then of course there's the issue of
the guaranteed
money the Steelers just don't give out
the heavy guarantees into the second
year into the third year like a lot of
teams do they've never done it their
salary structure isn't like that you
know instead what they do is they give
high yearly salaries and a huge signing
books and if bail spells gripe is the
guaranteed money and it is it's hard to
imagine the deal getting done
so being Rappaport my compadre from the
NFL media group here on the Rich Eisen
show the phrase we always talk about on
draft weekend as you know is it takes
one it just takes one team as take
somebody in the first round right it
just takes one is there a team in the
NFL do you think that would be willing
to set precedence if levian does get to
that unrestricted walk year next year I
mean does he believe I mean could his
agents go kick around and start start
feeling out who would be the team that
would go ahead and break precedents and
pay a bell in the manner in which he
wants to be paid that of course would be
illegal
honestly no agent would ever do that
there was also no gambling that was in
Casablanca that we were shocked about -
yeah yeah no it's yeah and now we're
gonna actually talk a lot about gambling
this year so the whole thing comes full
circle dice the yes I think that is what
Bell hopes that someone next year is
going to pay him fifteen million dollars
or sixteen million dollars per year to
be the best running back in the best fog
receiver in the NFL and free agency
we've seen players who have accomplished
far less received far more money I mean
Sammy Watkins is making 16 million
dollars a year with 2/3 of it guaranteed
and he has half the resume that Le'Veon
Bell has but we've never seen a running
back make free agency in his prime and
cash in like this we just haven't seen
it so it would be a leap I mean
obviously - what Le'Veon Bell is hoping
for and things continue like this there
will be no deal in two hours and we're
gonna find out but making a mistake it
is a dramatic leap for a levy on Bella
make - just assume that someone's going
to pay him like the top running back in
the NFL in free agency because we just
haven't seen these guys make a lot of
money in free agency so you know we
always read into things certainly when
Twitter's involved did you see what the
Steelers proshop tweeted out a couple
hours ago
I did okay we just described it for the
radio yeah let me let me just brock my
not know if you've seen this have you
seen this
I have not it is a photograph of four
jerseys that they are trying to sell
they're on sale okay certain matters the
home jersey ben roethlisberger the road
jersey of Antonio Brown the blast from
the past throwback jersey a juju Smith
Shuster and then there's a fourth
charity it's not levy on bail and it's
not anybody on defense it's any name it
says any name make your own make your
own Wow
Ian are they talking to Le'Veon Bell
here through a pro shop tweet you think
I mean it's the real question I would
have is just a pro shop clear with PR
maybe this is simply saying we want fans
to buy for the long term and these guys
are all here ben has any I mean do we
know Ben's gonna play more than 2018
like are we sure I'm sure they didn't
put Mason Rudolph Jersey up here I mean
right right I mean it's to me it's a
it's either an interesting little nudge
at Le'Veon Bell who no doubt is reading
and seeing everything as we get closer
or it's the most hilarious coincidence
in the history of Jersey promotions I'm
gonna go with option one okay and then
you're the last one for you the first
tweet I saw from you today I mean you
could have knocked me over for the
feather here or do we have a holdout
here
a rookie holdout already here it's not
even the middle of June practically
right now yeah yeah well I would say not
officially a holdout because the
veterans have a report yet but Rowland
Smith did not report leaders rookies to
the Chicago Bears today they basically
report in April because they play the
Hall of Fame game and he's not there and
you know it's interesting he is the same
age and as Joey Bosa hat
has he held out last year I'm not saying
it's going in that same direction but
same agent similar situation a holdout
over a rookie contract which you know
often gets done in the
of ours I am NOT ready to dismiss this
one and say oh it'll be fine I'm sure
I'll sign I don't I don't know that and
you know you can become very sort of
stubborn and firmly planted in these
contract situations meanwhile many of us
say things like ah these ordeals that
are already made and should be done
quickly you know this is the agents job
and he takes his stance and the player
believes in it then he may not report
for a little bit by the way I decided to
just Google Mason Rudolph while we were
talking about him
Ian the first photograph on how the
people do this
the first photograph that comes up is
Roethlisberger's from Mason Rudolph do
you google Mason Rudolph I'm gonna guess
Ben's people the same people who
seemingly block everyone in the world on
Twitter no not me well I'm gonna guess
they're behind ok great to chat with you
Ian it's really it was good to see what
the be at the I guess what the talent
summit couple of weeks ago where I
worked blue I dropped an f-bomb on no
yeah I told you that yeah I told you
that so it was good to see it's good to
see there it was it was fine I would say
it was show-stopping right that clearly
the best moment of the song and I'm not
and I'm not making fun it was I was
legitimately hilarious teracle a big
endorsement for that summit yes and do
take care all right ok brother team map
board you about to get real busy for him
and everybody else in the National
Football no wait the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience